[Musique]
il
bonjour et bienvenue dans un nouveau vip
aujourd'hui nous sommes au centre de
musique baroque de versailles avec
nicolas bûcher de directeur bonjour joue
alors le centre de musique baroque en
partenariat avec le château de
versailles france musique a lancé une
série de podcasts sur la chapelle royale
c'est en ligne pourquoi avoir choisi ce
format c'est même encore plus qu'un
podcast c'est un ex podcast c'est à dire
que ce qu'on a appelé ex podcast c'est à
la fois une exposition numérique et un
podcast et les deux sont intimement liés
éditorialement parlant et y compris dans
leur présentation
alors pourquoi ce choix je pense que le
centre de musique baroque de versailles
est connu comme étant un organisateur de
spectacles comme étant un lieu
d'enseignement comme étant un lieu de
musicologie un lieu de recherche et nous
travaillons depuis plusieurs années
aussi à se dire comment toucher un
public plus large
comment on essaye à de faire rentrer le
plus de monde possible dans cette danse
et cette musique baroque que nous aimons
tant et c'est pour ça qu'on s'est dit
que explorer la question du podcast de
l'exposition numérique c'était une bonne
occasion
alors comment ça se présente il ya du
son des textes des images d archives ya
à peu près tout ce que peut contenir un
objet numérique c'est à dire beaucoup de
choses en fait c'est ce sont six
épisodes de podcasts qu'on peut écouter
indépendamment de l'exposition numérique
c'est à dire qu'ils sont disponibles en
ligne sur la plateforme de france
musique où ils sont trouvables assez
facilement mais sont trouvables sur
notre site aussi et on peut un moment
aussi écouter simplement les six podcast
en faisant la cuisine en faisant une
activité pour laquelle on a on n'a pas
le regard enfin le regard est occupé
mais on peut aussi les constituent de
les consulter en regardant même temps le
site qui est dédié à sa qui s'appelle
être expo de caste point cmbv point fr
et où chaque podcast chaque épisode va
avoir toute une série de documents en
ligne et où il va aller voir comme vous
avez dit de l'image du texte de la vidéo
des animations
numérique à partir de certaines images
du son pur des pastilles audio est
exactement tout ce qu'en fait on peut
mettre sur un site en ligne mais qu'on
peut pas mettre en fait nulle part
ailleurs en fait c'est ça qu'on a essayé
de faire
donc l'idée c'est de découvrir ou de
redécouvrir la chapelle royale
alors d'abord pourquoi et qu'est-ce
qu'on ne peut retrouver dans ces six
épisodes de quoi ils parlent les uns et
les autres
alors pourquoi la raison c'est pour
cette première édition d'expo de caste
on voulait un thème qu'ils soient
fortement ancrée dans l'histoire du cmbv
est évidemment la relation avec le
château de versailles c'est un élément
fondateur du centre de musique baroque
de versailles et la maîtrise du centre
de baroque du centre de musique baroque
de versailles
la maîtrise chante tous les jeudis
quasiment dans la chapelle donc on s'est
dit que le lieu chapelle royale de
versailles était un bon un bon point de
départ pour créer cette exposition
thématique
ensuite on a confié l'écriture de le
commissariat de l'exposition l'écriture
de ce podcast à une jeune journaliste
qui s'appelle suzanne gervais et qui
nous en fait nous en a fait un grand
parcours de l'histoire des musiciens et
de la musique à la chapelle royale
depuis sa construction en 1710 jusqu'à
nos jours donc c'est vraiment un grand
parcours à travers l'histoire
une machine à remonter le temps de
l'activité musicale de ce lieu je crois
qu'il est aussi question donc de louis
xiv quel est le lien entre la chapelle
royale et louis xiv ben c'est le papable
de cette chapelle royale puisque c'est
louis xiv qui quand il fait agrandir
versailles quand il fait de venir ce
palais qui est à peu près aujourd'hui le
nôtre même si beaucoup de travaux
pendant le xviiie siècle aussi le 19e
siècle
en tout cas le dernier chantier
monumental de louis xiv à versailles
c'est la chapelle qu'il inaugure en 1710
c'est à dire cinq ans avant sa mort en
fait donc assez tardivement dans son
régne 1 vous avez dit que c'était le
premier thème la chapelle royale il
pourrait y en avoir d'autres ben nous
portons l'ambition effectivement de
faire une expo de caste parents et
voilà donc on nous travaillons d'ores et
déjà au deuxième épisode mais je ne vous
dirai pas de quoi on parle
est ce qu'on a besoin d'être un expert
ou un passionné pour écouter ses
podcasts ou s'est ouvert à tous pas du
tout alors en tout cas si on a réussi
notre pari et les premiers échos pour
que nous avons c'est que c'est plutôt
réussi
c'est qu'on s'adresse vraiment à tout le
monde j'ai une petite formule j'ai dit
en fait les deux prérequis pour pour
connaître un port pour pouvoir accéder à
cette chose là c'est de savoir à peu
près qui louis xiv est de savoir à peu
près ce que c'est qu'une chapelle dans
un dans un palais quoi une fois qu'on
sait ça on peut tout à fait entrer dans
cette expo de gaz dans ces podcasts
c'est très simple on l'a volontairement
c'est pas simpliste mais en même temps
c'est simple on l'a voulu accessible à
tous ceux qui ont envie de s'y plonger
la chose qui me paraît importante aussi
c'est de signaler qu'en fait chaque
épisode dire dure 10 à 12 minutes c'est
assez court parce que on espère que le
public n'aura pas peur de rentrer dans
un
dans un podcast de 12 minutes on essaye
en c'est intéressant on l'écouté c'est
pas intéressant on les confond l'arête
mais c'est pas comme commencer une
émission d'une heure et demie même si
l'intégralité des sites podcast font une
heure et quart et donc ses podcasts sont
en français en anglais il y avait une
volonté aussi de toucher plus que la
france oui tout à fait on s'est dit
quand on s'est lancé dans ce chantier
qui est un assez gros chantier
éditoriale c'est beaucoup de textes
beaucoup d'image beaucoup de sons enfin
un assez gros chantier à l'échelle de
maisons comme la nôtre que le conserver
uniquement dans la langue française
c'était beaucoup de travail pour pour
une diffusion assez restreinte
finalement donc on s'est dit qu'il
fallait panser mondiale sur un tel
projet et c'est pour ça que
l'intégralité des textes et traduites et
que le podcast est aussi on a été aussi
enregistrés en anglais par un anglophone
c'est aussi une façon de toucher les
touristes qui ne sont plus là en ce
moment je ne sais pas si on touche les
touristes à proprement parler en tout
cas on touche tous ceux qui un moment
vous
on s'intéressait de près ou de loin à la
musique à versailles et c'est pas
forcément des gens qui auraient fait le
voyage enfin je pense que on peut
espérer toucher plein de gens par des
détours qu'on n'imagine pas
aujourd'hui les archives toutes ses
photos ses textes y viennent d'où en
fait il ya des
les images originales c'est à dire des
photographies qu'on a fait nous des
beaucoup de photographies qui nous ont
été offertes par le château qui est
thomas gardien des photographes du
château et qui a photographié un peu la
chapelle sous toutes ses coutures donc
nous on a réutilisé c'est emile et
images là c'est un des enjeux de notre
partenariat avec le château est sur
cette opération
et puis après il ya énormément de dîners
chronographie de l'époque des tableaux
des peintures et donc tout ça c'est des
fonds de d'image notamment dont beaucoup
sont issus de la réunion des musées
nationaux qui est la structure nationale
qui photographie qui diffuse les images
qui font partie de notre patrimoine
vous êtes là l'initiative de ce grand
projet c'est nécessaire aujourd'hui de
se renouveler vu la situation actuelle
d'aller en ligne d'avoir d'autres
formats alors on n'a pas attendu le coup
vite pour penser numérique évidemment on
avait déjà pas mal d'outils numériques
au centre mais qui étaient plutôt des
outils de chercheurs plutôt des outils
pour vous est professionnel on va dire
et ça faisait honnêtement depuis mon
arrivée depuis deux ans et demi qu'on
réfléchissait à un outil numérique qui
soit accessible à un plus grand public
on était un petit peu au milieu du gué
et on avait du mal à trouver une formule
qui nous semblait convaincante et le
premier confinement a été le vrai
catalyseur sur ce projet là puisque
après l'abattement après la stupéfaction
des premiers jours j'ai ressorti ce
dossier qui était sous une pile en
disant un jour on fera un projet
numérique pour le grand public dix ans
c'est le moment ou jamais ressortons le
est justement dans une situation on est
face à ces ordis face à sa tablette face
sur la son téléphone qu'est-ce qu'on
aurait envie de voir et qu'est ce que le
centre est capable d'offrir dans ce
contexte et c'est comme ça qu'on
aboutisse à ce projet alors qu'est ce
qu'on trouve dans ces six épisodes tel
est le contenu les grands thèmes alors
on commence par l'évocation de la
construction de la chapelle et de son
inauguration c'est comme ça que commence
le podcast ce qui permet en fait de
faire un petit pas en arrière et de voir
quelle est l'histoire de la place de la
musique sacrée dans la royauté en
remontant très très loin c'est un petit
peu de ça c'est le premier point
ensuite très vite on s'intéresse à la
messe durant
c'est à dire que louis xiv mais ses
successeurs aussi entendez la messe tous
les jours et donc de la musique tous les
jours qu'ils étaient écrites pour la
messe du roi donc suffisamment retrace
le déroulé de cet événement quotidien
qui avait lieu donc tous les jours à la
chapelle royale
ensuite on traite un événement important
en 783 oui 14 organise un grand concours
à travers toute la france pour recruter
ses musiciens ses maîtres de chapelle
dont on compterait de ce concours qui
était organisée manière extrêmement
moderne en fait on parle de michèle
richard delalande qui est le grand
compositeur qui va occuper la chapelle
royale pendant près d'un demi siècle
on parle du grand motet qui est la forme
musicale qu'on chantait essentiellement
à la cour à l'époque
et puis le dernier volet est consacré à
la au rayonnement de la chapelle à
l'étranger et qu'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui dans cette chapelle royale
quelle est la musique que l'on fait
aujourd'hui que ce soit nous le centre
de musique baroque de versailles où nos
collègues château de versailles
spectacles qui sont les organisateurs
des spectacles et des concerts à dacca
au château la messe du roi elle était
très importante si je ne me trompe pas
les quatorze la très rarement loupé très
exactement alors là d'une part ils
étaient présents quotidiennement et il
paraîtrait saint-simon nous dit qu'ils
auraient raté la messe une fois dans sa
vie
et la deuxième chose c'est qu'il
attendait qu'on que d'autres que lui
y participent d'autres pas et ensuite il
était extrêmement pointilleux sur la
bouffe ponctualité et la présence de
tous ces musiciens pour pour les moments
de musique de cette messe qui était
entièrement musique de a à z en fait
d'accord trade
merci beaucoup nicolas bûcher avec
plaisir je vous rappelle que les
épisodes sont déjà disponibles depuis le
12 novembre
merci beaucoup et à bientôt
[Musique]
il
oui